est-ce que cette rencontre prévue à
Matignon peut selon vous débloquer la
situation vous dites enfin ou trop tard
j'ai dit bien trop tard mais enfin
bien trop tard on a une quand même des
semaines et des semaines de
manifestation et il n'y a pas eu la
moindre invité invitation à se rendre à
Matignon quelle est cette première
ministre quelle est cette première
ministre qui ne reconnaît pas les
syndicats alors que les syndicats je le
rappelle pour être représentatifs sont
élus donc ils ont une légitimité à
porter la contestation sociale et à
représenter les salariés et bien c'est
la question et c'est pour ça que moi je
pense que enfin voilà on nous les
groupes politiques n'allons pas y aller
parce que nous naissons les syndicats y
aller en premier et que je pense que
c'est respectueux du combat incroyable
qu'on menait les syndicats ces dernières
semaines mais moi j'aurais vraiment aimé
qu'on ne serait pas non nous n'y seront
pas nous n'y seront pas parce que c'est
au syndicat d'être entendu en premier
parce que c'est leur mouvement et que ça
se respecte et que nous nous sommes en
arrière-plan de ce mouvement nous
relayons ce mouvement mais nous n'en
sommes pas au premier plan mais moi
j'aurais aimé vraiment rentrer dans
Matignon et lui demander de démissionner
j'aurais aimé le faire avec son
gouvernement je l'ai dit pour Gérald
Darmanin parce que toute la séquence
pour pour eux et en l'occurrence avoir
un conflit social de cette ampleur là
historique de plusieurs semaines et ne
pas tendre la main une seule fois une
seule fois au syndicat ça n'est pas
raisonnable ça n'est pas raisonnable et
ça met la France à feu et à 100 tout ça
pour 10 milliards d'euros d'économies
tout ça pour un modèle productiviste
tout ça pour quelque chose qui
finalement ne fait qu'aggraver les
problèmes dans lesquels nous sommes qui
sont le réchauffement climatique et la
crise sociale
quand est-ce qu'on prend en compte le
bien commun au nom de quoi fait-on les
politiques publiques alors vous le
disiez les parlementaires de gauche
refusent cet entretien avec la première
ministre à Matignon il les appelle
plutôt et bien à marcher jusqu'à
l'Elysée mardi quel est le but de cette
marche vers l'Elysée c'est de mettre
encore plus la pression sur le président
de la République c'est de dire que
Emmanuel Macron est le grand ordonnateur
de cette séquence et que il ne va pas se
défausser de ses responsabilités parce
qu'on voit et ça c'est aussi un des
traits de sans doute de caractère
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est que dès que la
situation devient un peu compliquée et
bien il accuse sa première ministre et
il a même je crois utilisé ce mot de
stupide qui me semble quand même devoir
être interrogé en démocratie quand un
président de la République traite ainsi
sa première ministre mais c'est lui qui
est responsable de cette séquence il en
a fait vraiment une affaire presque
presque personnelle
identitaire en tous les cas de son
mandat de faire cette réforme des
retraites il a même dit que ce second
mandat ne débuterait qu'à partir du
moment où cette réforme des retraites
aurait été et donc
c'est lui le responsable de cette
séquence et c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'il est important aussi de se
positionner vis-à-vis d'Emmanuel Macron
en leur disant nous ne sommes pas du
tout en lui disant pardon nous ne sommes
pas dupe et nous serons là et nous
savons que c'est vous qui soufflez sur
les braises d'une France qui va mal et
vous allez tous marcher vers l'Élysée y
compris avec les Français
j'ai pas encore discuté avec les autres
groupes politiques mais peut-être
pourquoi pas ce serait bien que les
Français manifestent devant l'Élysée
selon vous je pense qu'il y a un rapport
de force directe à instaurer avec le
président de la République oui
[Musique]